day one of the inaugural st. Louis rapid  in Flint the fourth stop of the year on  the grand chessboard one of the most  anticipated chess availa tiers and  finally arrived and some of the best  players in the world kept their fans  from the edges of their seats  the legendary champion Garry Kasparov  made his return to professional  competitions and after three fighting  draws he finds himself in the middle of  the pack well I would likely lose my  foolish because my plan was disallowed  they want American star Fabiano Khurana  bounce back from a stunning first round  loss with back-to-back wins and is now  tied with three other players a Tom  standing the thrills and spills continue  as the players try to show their best  form they fluff rapid coming up Nick  [Music]